weeks into his new job as a freshman
member of Congress and just months from
his previous life of near total
anonymity right George Santos has
somehow transformed into the single most
dangerous and historically significant
figure on the global stage today so we
have here already two tools that are
used we have what about ism
and we have
um you could call it reductio ad
absurdum you could call it straw Manning
so so the what about ism is Tucker
Carlson shifting from a discussion about
Biden to one about how George Santos has
been treated which are actually two
completely different things no matter
what Tucker tries to tell you and then
the sort of straw Manning is the idea
that Democrats are telling you Santos is
the most dangerous guy in the world
Democrats aren't telling you Santos is
they're saying he's laughably dishonest
and has no place in the House of
Representatives which is true